we do have Mark green back can you hear
me congressman
yeah I got you loud and clear you guys
hear me okay we hear you beautifully my
question to you sir was besides the
impeachment of my orcas what are the
first steps you and your fellow
Republicans are going to do in Congress
to secure our Southern border
well there are a lot of things we can do
I think some of the first steps are of
course to request information from the
Department so that we can go and hold
accountable uh the crazy Lawless
dereliction of Duty from the from the
secretary we can also pass legislation
uh that supports the financial aid
packages to countries in Central America
and actually has them implement the MPP
they can actually you know start putting
people back into the countries that that
people actually come from so there's a
lot of things that we can do uh and
we're gonna do it well Congressman Pat
Fallon made Big Time news yesterday by
filing these articles of impeachment
against Alejandro mayorcas it's
something that a lot of Republicans do
want to see but realistically is that
going anywhere
so what we've got to do is get to the
bottom of what's happened you know my
committee is not the jurisdiction for
impeachment that's the Judiciary
Committee my job will be to go get the
details so we we're sending letters over
to the department so we'll subpoena
emails all that kind of stuff and do the
due diligence and then we're going to
have secretary mayorkas come in and
we're going to look at the laws that
haven't been enforced we're going to
inform the American people about the
dollars that have been wasted uh with
NGO contracts and things like that so a
lot of a lot of things we're going to be
digging into and then if it looks like
he needs to be impeached we'll hand that
off to the Judiciary Committee we should
have started off with a big
congratulations to you on your upcoming
role as chairman of the homeland
security committee and you really have
your work cut out for you especially
when it does come to the border and 96
people on the terror watch list were
caught trying to cross into the country
which begs the question through those
porous areas where there is no border
fencing how many people that want to do
the American people harm to get through
so
um how do you address that issue
so there's a number of different ways
right so we need new technology we need
to support our CBP folks that they they
are having a difficult time retaining uh
personnel and also uh hiring new
personnel and and something as simple as
a polygraph or a former veteran who who
has to go through this this very arduous
process to get hired and you know if
we've got a veteran who had a successful
military career why don't we just put
them in CBP but it's it's simple things
like that that can and very quickly make
a difference at the southern border but
we've got to take yeah we got to take
control back from the drug cartels this
president has basically given control to
the drug cartels with the massive waves
of people coming across at the Crossing
sites they've been the line in the rural
areas fentanyl pours in we we can
address that by our authorizing
legislation that demands that the you
know the the DHS folks do it the way
it's supposed to be done Point Blank
Congressman you are now chair of the
house Homeland Security committee will
our homeland be more secure or than it
was the past two years
100 100
percent
Congress yes Mark green congratulations
again on your appointment wish you the
best of luck you got a lot in your plate
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm means Lee Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis